hey YouTube averse Startalk coming up
cosmic queries quirky queries this is
Startalk Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist got Paul
Mercurio co-host wait to be Oh welcome
back yeah oh he's fun damn near old
timer now with us that's good
this episode is a cosmic queries and
they named it for me
I had nothing to do with it quirky
questions cosmic quirky queries quirky
queries some of a grab-bag to me so I
don't know where they're coming from but
Paul you got the question alright so
bring it bring it alright we have a
patreon oh yeah I forgot they get in
they slip in oh yeah Jacob behind the
behind a rope they come in come in first
Jacob Horton could the solar system have
a stable 2 star system yeah
yeah it can well first any pair of stars
will be stable I think what he really
means by that is if you had two stars
with the planet orbits be stable among
those two stars so the if if you're
gonna have planets orbiting a star and
you want to throw in a second star what
that others start to be very close to
the first one so that as they orbit your
planet out here you don't see really two
stars because they're just so close
together in orbit around each other you
see one sort of smeared large star there
if you're too close or if they are
orbiting too far away from each other
your orbital Allegiance will be tested
all the time
here are two stars orbiting each other
now you're orbiting the two stars one
day you're closer to this star the next
day you're not who who do you belong to
who's your daddy right yeah and so this
can greatly disrupt the stability of
your orbit in that system
and therefore the stability of the
planet the planet orbit itself nothing
sorry
not only the planet orbit but also your
climate l2 is the living condition right
because sometimes you're close to a star
sometimes you're farther away over short
periods of time
so that'll wreak havoc on your climate
there's no stable tide
for you to evolve in because it's
running ran shackle annually if not
monthly in addition not only does it
affect your climate you orbit is
affected you're close to one you're
gonna slingshot around that you're gonna
come around another hey can go hey while
you go hey why I love the word in this
context and so some of the planets will
fall in others will get ejected so the
only stable orbits around binary star
systems are ones that are very far away
relative to the separation of the two
stars themselves so that the two stars
just look like one object that they're
orbiting because they are close together
close enough together so if this were
our place your fist and and they're a
star on this side and this side and it's
not work it is it possible that they
could sort of orbit very restricted
cases there's a there's a figure eight
orbit that exists otherwise they might
slam into each other yeah it's just not
you know you were gonna be orbiting
outside of both systems not orbiting in
and through them you could you could fly
spaceship around it that'd be fun but no
these are not stable orbits another way
to get a stable orbit put a star way the
hell outside of the solar system I'm
sorry outside of where the planets are
orbiting all eight of them hmm way
outside then you're orbiting in here you
don't even know it's out do you don't
care right the Stars the two stars know
about each other
but you don't you just you're committed
to one star no you don't you know
significantly feeling what's going on
out there you just to keep in your in
your part and I've always said I'm a one
star guy yeah that's that's a little
stable situation out there yeah
especially since you can be consumed in
fire it vaporizes on the spot yeah all
right next question
all right the last Kingsguard on
Instagram is it possible that humans are
the most intelligent species in the
universe no next question I agree with
you I don't know why is there not
sufficient evidence collected yet
Syriana I'll give you one reason because
people review plungers on Amazon really
I went to buy a plunger and there was
five hundred and six
seven reviews of one plunger I go gather
your belongings and move to the woods
people it's over yeah I'm not joking
most intelligent species okay finish the
question just give me a chance okay is
it possible the most intelligent species
in the universe and there is no
intelligent species out there other than
us okay so if there's no other life in
the universe I think it's fair for us to
say that we're the most intelligent
species that ever existed on earth and
ever existed in the universe if there's
no other life out there however who
defines humans as being intelligent and
what doesn't tell no I'm asking you
what's the answer to that question
humans humans thank you you see a not
intelligent I just blowing my mind you
ma'am I'm here and not here where am I I
don't know just answer the question and
leave me alone will ya humans you're
right who defines humans as intelligent
humans do okay now what's our DNA
difference from chimps you would have
learned this in biology class how much
it's like 1 or 2 percent like 1%
difference
do we count chimps as intelligent well
sure if you're a chimp fan but not
intelligent on the level of humans
chimps are not building airplanes and
flying to chimp cities right humans
aren't throwing their poop so chips
really throw their poop is that just a
thing if they have a delivery it comes
late they go crazy you know that X is
late what if it's good I wonder you get
them in the major leagues you know we
have teams the Commissioner of the poop
throwing 90 mile an hour fastball fast
food so what is the smartest chimp do
and the primatologist will bring them
forward and say oh I I've said this
before but I'm on the internet probably
multiple times saying exactly this but
I'll do it for you ok
that the smart chip will stock stack
boxes and reach a banana right we'll get
a stick that's just right that can go
inside the termite hole and yeah the
termites out this takes some and there
was cocoa the sign language yeah I think
Coco was a gorilla I'm but that's fine
but same primates the the greater apes
and I wanted to get make a joke about
that you know he wasn't just a good
gorilla he was a great ape you know I'm
trying to get the right lead into that
but that's my punch line all right we'll
work on it later Jimmy there you helped
get me there so so if there's only one
percent that separates us yet they stack
boxes and we have a Hubble telescope and
poetry and philosophy and art and
comedians then that they were listed
last in that thanks you that was really
just so you can say well what a
difference that 1% makes you might say
right but let's take a cosmic
perspective on it if there's only 1%
difference between us maybe there's only
really a 1% intelligence difference as
well maybe stacking boxes to each a
banana is only 1% intelligence away from
the Hubble telescope and poetry and
philosophy and music and art it seems
like a stretch so that's that's one it
seems like it should be more than 1%
because you are human and human ego
knows no bounds so let's do the
experiment let's go out in the universe
and find some other creature that's 1%
smarter than us in the same way that we
are 1% smarter than chimps what would we
look like to them right what does a
chimp look like to us so our smartest
human because what the smartest chimp
does things that toddlers can do
toddlers can figure out
stack boxes toddlers can figure that out
whoo-hoo it's a smart chimp our toddlers
do it let's bring in this other species
show them the smartest human Steven Hauk
rolls Stephen Hawking out you know roll
Stephen Hawking out there he is they
would say of Stephen Hawking this one is
slightly smarter than the rest but only
slightly smarter because he can do
astrophysics calculations in his head
like little Timmy over here who just
came home from preschool and they don't
allow cute Tim oh you just derived the
principles of calculus put it on the
refrigerator door all this okay oh you
just compose a sonnet grandma they're so
intelligent why do they still have
refrigerators no no no they don't have
refrigerated doors you'll have a frigid
they just have refrigerator doors okay
because they got to put the kid art
somewhere in the kitchen so it's so
smart I never feature it's such a
brilliant non sequitur people don't need
refrigerator I'm here to point out the
obvious stuff that the unintelligent
speech
I'm representing the unintelligent so my
point is what would their simplest
thoughts look like to us here's a simple
thought that is inconceivable to a chimp
Paul I'll meet you tomorrow at Starbucks
we'll have a latte and we'll get on the
plane together go to Washington and have
that meeting in Congress okay
what does any of that mean is it
comprehensible at all to a chimp what is
a latte that could be just a definition
but we're gonna fly to that fly would it
why are you a bird no how do you fly
well we invented it how did you invent
it it required technology required metal
and engines and fuel and understanding
Bernoulli's principle this is our
thoughts that we all take for granted
that is inconceivable to a chimp I
year the simplest thoughts from this
other species that we would they would
lay down the simplest thought and we
would be poring over it with our most
brilliant humans for centuries not
understanding it and they'll just laugh
at us and put us in a zoo and we'll be
their entertainment so we figuring out
calculus and spaceflight and the Hubble
telescope is to them what chimps
throwing poop is to us okay
you hear that scientists at MIT they're
just throwing poo you poop throwers but
here's the thing what do you think there
is life out there
I'm not giving reason to doubt that
there is given how old the universe is
how big it is and how prevalent the
ingredients for life on Earth are across
the universe and why do you use the word
fear no joke why do you use the word
fear for that proposition that there may
be a species out there that's 1% more
intelligent than we are no no the fear
is linked you well they give us their
simplest sentence and we just have no
idea what they're talking about so I
don't want to be that stupid I want to
say look at me I know how you feel I'm
totally with you on that that's why I
went I was not involved this is why I
don't hang out with you a lot because
you are that species from another planet
no doesn't throw its poop no and your
butt problem is you're like 20 percent
smarter than I am
so I want to believe that the human
intellect is sufficient to solve any
problem given enough time and enough
people and enough cleverness but the
proposition that such a species exists
knowing that their simplest sentence may
be incomprehensible to us I fear it only
because I don't want to be that dumb I
want to believe that all problems in the
universe in the universe are tractable
by the human mind and this would be an
example that clearly it's not to me
and it could be the best evidence for
why we've never been visited by aliens
because they've scoured the universe for
other intelligent species and they saw
no sign of it on earth well-put next
question and you want to know why they
know that because people are reviewing
plungers on Amazon right you know this
is really no I hate my other hypotheses
for why they never was
they actually have visited but they
accidentally came during comic-con and
nobody noticed it some other aliens here
already you know damn let's go find
somewhere else and where were the first
visitor you know that is perfect okay
this is somewhat related so this is a
good next question Mohammed Khan
Facebook when do you think it will be
possible to achieve immortality I think
it has been suggested and I'm not giving
reason to doubt this that the first
person to live forever is already alive
yeah it's Beyonce everybody knows that
answer came way too quickly offer you're
done yeah so the the notion what enables
that sentence to possibly be true is
that get someone who's just born today
hmm so we're working on the genome we
writing the aging gene whatever that is
if the even is such a thing and we say
okay we can now that newborn person when
they're 20
they will we take this potion and they
can now live to be 150 there would be a
major advance on our longevity by the
time they're 40 we that we've improved
the potion now they can live to 300 by
the time they're 60 now they can live to
500 by the time they're 80 now they can
live to a thousand by the time they're
hundred they can live for a million
years that's the notion that we'll make
incremental improvements that will
continue to accrue for the person who is
just born today and what do scientists
or people in this field working on or
thinking about it see as a potential
hazard of that I mean what could go
wrong yes exactly
so a couple of things very important one
of two things has to have
either we colonize other planets or you
stop making babies mmm because if you
don't die and you keep making babies
that ups the population growth rate you
probably can grow through eight relies
on the fact that some people die and
food resources in general that's correct
so you need other planets if you if you
if you're not smart enough to have
technology to get to other planets
living forever is not a good idea and I
have a rebuttal to living forever what's
that what motivation would you have to
even wake up tomorrow morning and get
anything accomplished at all well let's
see you go don't you think because you
could all that's in there too but I'm
what I'm asking is isn't the knowledge
that you're going to die give focus and
meaning to your life yes I have a child
and like if you all of us and I'm
serious I have a child I think you know
you have a limited amount of time in on
this earth you doesn't make sure you
spend the time with it whereas if it's
open-ended it's like a house you know
let's see in 20 years if I was wrong the
following wouldn't be true have you ever
given your loved ones plastic flowers
it's my wife she's shaking her head no
no let's do better than plastic have you
ever given your loved ones silk flowers
no I've stolen them from a funeral okay
now why not why are you giving her
flowers
that you know in advance will die I know
the answer because knowledge that the
flowers will die magnify the meaning and
the attention you give it while they're
alive that is the meaning of limited
longevity you live a different way you
ompletely approach different way I'm a
different perspective now let me now
pull something out of my ass why is the
dog so excited to see you when you come
home the dog only lives 14 years
whatever is your excitement that spent
seven times that amount of years alive
it just imagine your entire life you not
have to experience in 14 years what
would you do you would do it
every day outside Oh someone but I can
smell let me smell as many butts as I
can oh my gosh okay
there's there's everything they do
you're right such intensity I always say
my dog is too optimistic I'm not a big
fan of it but they're not optimistic if
you only live 14 years they're just
right so it's I don't mean to
psychologically analyze dogs this is
what I'm suggesting to you is that what
they look like to us is as though
they're packing life's intensity in a
concentrated way of 14 years yes
but seriously why is it excited because
they think I wasn't gonna come back I
don't have a why I'm just actually I'm
pulling it down my ass I'm suggesting
that we question the enthusiasm dogs
exhibit hmm like this was wholly
unjustified look I just came home
look I just went out to get a quart of
milk you know I think it's because they
had an accident on the couch that's in
the list but if you went out for an hour
to them it's 14 hours maybe right you
gone for a day to them it's two weeks in
our lifespan that's what it is well we
just hit me with this conversation is
there is such an interrelation between
science and psychology and human beings
in the human the human condition and now
you have to take all of that into
account in doing I try to every day of
my life yeah so knowledge that I will
die gives focus and meaning to what I do
in life so if I live forever think what
am i doing well that's why that means
just not the on-demand choices would be
terrible every single thing on your
cable system
no no they'll make if everyone else is
living forever they'll still make movies
faster than you can watch it you know if
you're not gaining on this one ball
weight that means we can get more police
academy movies all right here's one from
this is Kenyon read Instagram what
science fiction concept would you most
like to see in a real world application
very clear work drive I want to visit
the
side of the galaxy x-ray vision man we
already have x-ray vision they call
x-ray we can already see through things
but I want it like in glasses and I can
see what I'm you know you read 20 comics
as a kid we have x-ray specs at the back
where you can buy them the x-ray vision
why do you want to see through to good
score round it and you have a much
better view of it under the clothes oh
you want to be that's a different that's
a different issue of have you spoken
about this with your accountant
I'd say you're saying it's easy what's
the answer by the way any vision that
sees through clothes also sees through
flesh I'm just giving you the reality of
it so psyched for this I'm just saying
that's what it is
so so you don't see through clothes and
then just see the body of the person you
seen through the body of the person you
see their bones and rings they're
wearing another their metal hip that's
got replaced five years ago that's what
you're seeing with x-rays that's know
you we have much better power of longing
than just do you want to see an X rays
yes warp drives you get anywhere you
want in the universe and you think that
will be something at some point that's
not what the question was
so just what would I most want to see
not that I think what was the most
likely is it likely that that would
happen
I'm skeptical yeah yeah it's too
complicated to figure I know it's just
it's too it's too out there now don't
trust me because when I first start
trust our Trek and they had this box
then they put food in it came out a few
seconds later hot I said nah that'll
never well you're pressuring because we
have Mel Powell at melp our next
question go what is it asked wort wort
drive someday yes or no that's the
question you just answered it so there
you go I will go out on a limb and say
no so that is 300 years you can go back
and play the tape of me saying no as you
wish by me at warp speed we're about to
go to break but well you had a message
yes you tubers don't miss any of the
episodes of Startalk how just below
click on the bell subscribe
Startalk cosmic queries quirky queries
additional ball yes give it to me
here we go remember just you're tweeting
at pole and Mercurio a me see you
alright and you can check out my podcast
of Paul Mercurio show that's the name of
the show yeah I name we had a big thing
Palmateer o's name of a show folk the
Paul Mercurio you know we we had we sat
around the table 12 of us we spit ball
names and that's it for a day and that's
what you came out with now you're in
good hands there was the Andy Griffith
Show right and you know Seinfeld it's
just I felt right so high well I tried
two chairs and a microphone for a while
whatever but then there wasn't as cool
as between the ferns exactly but the
other thing you helped me with you gave
me a suggestion for sure name which I'm
using so all right here we go
Sammy John Lennon Instagram do you
believe a Mulla Mulla was just an
unusual space rock or an alien probe
[Laughter]
this long and sweat I mean it's like -
its what is that all about like why do
people jump to that when they start
talking about aliens white what what I
should always anything that you could
think of that they would do and you
can't they came here while probing your
organs right yeah obsession with my anus
what do they are they all
gastrointestinal doctors is that it they
all want to be part ologist try to put
around us to make money come on people
you're better than that
okay ready you ready so a mu amor is the
first confirmed interstellar visitor to
our solar system it's a rock right can I
be more poetic about it please once you
let me ride this one it's got a
beautiful Hawaiian name which means
scout basically except it's repeated and
in some languages Hawaiian included if
you repeat something it's done for
emphasis so the mullah is a scout Oh
mwah mwah is a scout scout
so the
it's the first visitor from interstellar
space that we have ever confirmed moved
through our solar system and it is
trivial to learn whether it belongs here
or comes from elsewhere you just look at
how fast it's going how do we know that
it was that it's from another I'm
getting there so you look how you
measure how fast it's going and you say
at that speed it is moving too fast for
the Sun to contain it it is too fast for
it to orbit the Sun it will come into
the solar system in one side and come
out the other side our gravity will
alter its path but it's not going to
wrap it around into orbit so so there
are four kinds of orbits you can have
you can have a circle and ellipse
slightly flattened circle a parabola
which is an ellipse that's so big and
open that it's open on the other side
and the thing never closes back on
itself okay
or a hyperbola which is even greater
than everything a parabola was and if
you find something that has a hyperbolic
trajectory it was born somewhere else
and it's going somewhere where you're
not so be like Neil deGrasse Tyson is a
genius like that kind of hyperbole
well those so the hyper is root to many
uses and the term hyperbola is a shape a
geometric shape hyperbola and it's the
most extreme of the energies of these
orbits hyperbole is language that's
excessive and unwarranted usually and
what else you have hyperdrive hyperspace
these are things are beyond and beyond
the normal so this rock is this had that
would not great for rock yet okay this
visitor its visitor yes so it that told
us it came from somewhere else outside
of the solar system on a one-way visit
so now you add up all the gravity that
we have that could be affecting its
trajectory and you find out it's all the
difference
what are you gonna do about that
different than the one you calculate yes
and we know how to calculate your
victories we got this we know Newton's
laws of gravity so you so the question
becomes when did it get altered and how
did it get all correct
finally or is this somebody altering it
consciously on board if something is
moving non gravitationally something's
in charge of it that's not gravity if
something is moving through space and
just all of a sudden starts slowing down
something's controlling it in fact
that's the opening scene of the movie
the remake of the movie The Day the
Earth Stood Still we detect some fast
moving thing in the solar system with
hyperbolic speeds headed towards Earth
and then it rapidly begins to slow down
it's alien it's being controlled by
aliens but if that were true why all
serious is why would it not it surely is
sophisticated enough to be able to sense
that there are beings on this planet and
not stop to explore or you mean okay so
now it's not just am i controlling my
orbit am i actually analyzing
destinations that's a whole how much do
you want out of this rock so you saying
it may not be Iraq no so so because its
orbit its trajectory around the Sun was
not quote following Newton's laws that
meant something was affecting its
trajectory and some hypothesized maybe
it's an intelligent craft if there's not
actual aliens on it maybe they're active
navigational tools on it that go into
autopilot as they near a star or being
controlled remote no because they would
be too far how do you know that if you
are the speed of light if you can't
define with that what's not okay okay so
if they controlling it from afar they'd
have to use subspace communication
systems such as what they do in Star
Trek because on Star Trek if they're
going warp speed how they're going to
send a signal ahead of them if they're
moving faster than the beam of light
itself that they would be sending
move ahead of them FedEx it's amazing
they're amazing I'm telling you always
on time
so what you need is a FedEx that can
deliver backwards of time you know I
need you to get this this year yesterday
we've got it here we huh yesterday sir
watch the extra so that's why the alien
reference so that's why there's a it was
hypopneas did it but there are other
ways a trajectory can be influenced as
you near the Sun if you have ice content
the Sun will evaporate that ice in the
ice out gases oh now you have a little
you know retro rockets that couldn't
alter which way your object is moving so
there there are other ways that it could
be influenced and I'm not gonna jump to
conclusions and say it's aliens hmm I'm
not gonna rule it out but I'd rather not
that beat my first suggestion but the
end just to wrap this up on this subject
there is not it's gone so any analysis
of it is done whatever we've done yeah
it's it's left the solar system
incorrect okay well sorry it's it's it
exited out the back door right right but
it's still out there but it's it's no
longer in Europe enough to our sensors
and detectors and telescopes again any
meaningful data any further yeah so Abu
amour is Hawaiian for Scout that was
discovered using telescopes on Mauna Kea
in Hawaii yeah so just out of respect
for the culture and things it's not the
only thing that has a Hawaiian name a
lot is discovered from that and your
this thing they speculate is between 300
and 3200 feet yeah I forgot the exact
number I forgot but it's about that it's
about that I'm moving that fast like
again they can they can do a fairly
accurate measurement oh yeah well well
yeah fairly accurate they know it's
elongated and one of my concerns is when
you have elongated things in space it's
usually an asteroid that broke apart
from the tide forces of whatever it last
went close to and it gets stretched in
front and behind itself and if it's a
solid object it breaks into pieces that
extend in front behind itself and so
that it's not a solid object that it's
just this because it's a very long
cigar-shaped object yeah
John Laird at Jon Leuer t7 Twitter what
is the most counterintuitive thing about
the nature of the universe that's true
despite seeming false at first glance I
love that question and I've never been
asked it before thank you what's the
guy's name
John Laird John thank you for that
question
beautiful question but counterintuitive
let me think
so counter that there's not a
chick-fil-a
at more restaurants companies the coast
that's counterintuitive well except that
if you're traveling on Sunday you can't
buy from them cuz they're closed on
Sunday that's right and that makes
there's more travel traffic you know
tourists you know um trip traffic on the
weekends then so half the time he's not
gonna be there good point
just saying yeah okay because on the
seventh day God rested yeah and Sbarro
of it to fill in the gaps by the way you
know the actual seventh day was not
Sunday it was Saturday yeah yeah that's
wise the Jewish Sabbath is Saturday and
why why and what is what is what is
Saturday and we're Romance languages you
know what in Spanish what is it in
Italian Saturday
aren't you Italian I am today Salomon so
I don't in Spanish Sabbath Oh let cetera
so Sabbath that's the seventh day why
did he get why did sunday become the
because Christians worked very hard to
distinguish themselves from the Jews who
preceded them so we can't celebrate the
height the height of the the holy day
the same day as the Jews because we're
different so they moved it physically
moved it to Sunday so that is the holy
day on the Christian calendar Saturday
is the holy day on the Jewish calendar
as you all know and it begins at sunset
the day before Friday right all right so
sunset Friday to sunset Saturday and
Plus this sunset rule can only exist if
you live between the arctic circles
because it would go north of the Arctic
the Sun never sets or it never Rises
that's why there's no there are no Jews
in the park no if I went north of the
Arctic Circle Mike's right now to find
the synagogue
and I was it possible to see you just
you get disappointed in life okay John
Laird what is the most counterintuitive
thing about the nature of the universe
that is true despite seeming false at
first glance counterintuitive are you
ready let's go way back on this one that
earth is moving through space at 18
miles per second and you have no
knowledge of this we have to measure
this but to figure this out with
telescopes with smart people with data
with calculations we associate in motion
with hey I can feel I'm in motion I can
feel that but the more pure motion
becomes the less you feel it that's why
on very large vessels if they start
moving you don't even know they started
moving because everything around you is
move your chair you're win - everything
found a bus sometimes it looks like the
other bus went backwards no you started
going forward hmm on so basically the
larger the vessel the less aware you are
of how much that vessel is moving
you could be on an ocean liner and it
can start to start leaving port you
would and oh my gosh we left because
you're surrounded by so many things that
are also moving and everything is moving
smoothly if you're on bumpy roads you
would know right so if I'm on that boat
and it's stuck but moving through space
is smooth can't get smoother than that
until so the relevance of that in
relation to this question is you're
saying that the year it's not intuitive
that earth is moving anywhere and this
is why we went thousands of years was
people thinking earth was stationary in
the center of the known universe what is
making it move it's not what's making it
move it's that if a moved much slower it
would fall into the Sun and we would all
die and it move much faster we would
escape from the solar system and we'd be
a vagabond planet in interstellar space
so the only planets that survived the
formation of the solar system are the
ones that had the right speed at the
right distance to sustain in orbit and
there's eight of them get over it eight
so for me that that's it that's an old
school one you want a modern one yes
it's not intuitive here we go it's not
intuitive that when tidewaters come in
and out on the shoreline you are
actually sitting on a rotating earth
passing through a tide that is
stationary in space right because what I
sit there I think oh the water's coming
in going out coming in going out you're
on earth that is rotating inside and out
of a high and low tides of tidal both
it's a tidal bulge that's right so to me
now we we had another cosmic queries
where we spent a lot of time on that
topic but I think that's a good one if
because it looks like waters moving in
and out but you're the one moving
through the tide yeah see I did that
that to me is counterintuitive yeah and
I wouldn't believe you know and I got
another one you ready yes okay a lot of
people want to know what happens after
they die okay
evidence shows he put together all
scientific evidence biological and
physics and thermodynamic let people
mock you you have no existence after you
die and you said well what does that
feel like if you say I'm no he says what
does that like wait a minute
we use no existence as a physical body
or just everything about you that says
you exist now that you tell yourself I
exist I think therefore I am
mm-hmm in terms of my presence in the
unit yes how is gone you will have no
existence on death laws of physics and
biology tell us that you can believe
what you want in a country where we have
protection of religious expression but
if you want to ask science what science
says about it you go into a state of
non-existence you can say well why is
that what's that like mmm I'll tell you
exactly what it's like this is what it
was like before you were born
hmm you're not asking yourself what was
like before I was born
I had to have some existence you didn't
you have no existence a state of
non-existence before you were born so
I'm not given reason to think that your
state of non-existence in death differs
in any fundamental way from your state
of non-existence before you're born
giving that much more meaning to what it
is you can and should do while you're
alive hmm in this world hmm that's a
good point and and afterlife for you
know that concept I'm not convinced and
because I'm not convinced I'm doing as
much as I can in my own life yeah yeah
that's true I don't want to say I'm
looking forward to afterlife so I'm
gonna chill on the beach you know it's
true you're a greeter at Walmart on the
side in my spare time do it as much as
you can
next question okay this is Sam pond go
saw at Facebook mm-hmm where does the
line of limits lie in engineering
science or creativity oh I love that I
will answer that question when we return
from this next break so probably I go to
break but you haven't yeah I want to be
loving this and I don't know how you're
not subscribed to the show click on the
bell below and do not miss any episodes
of star talk we're back star talk cosmic
queries rookie queries edition all nice
to be here give it to me pick it right
back up who else do you have
Sam Pongo saw Facebook where does the
line of limits lie in engineering
science or creativity ooh
it's both people ask questions and they
assume it has to be one or the other we
somehow we know we don't allow blended
solutions to things and that's wrong
sometimes the actual answer is in
between the extremes but we'd like
arguing extremes because we like a fight
well I think we're also tribal by nature
and we want to be in one group at Yahoo
that's probably the deepest reason of
them all then I'm done right now I'm not
gonna top that so it's are you and my
camp were the other person's camp so I
think it's both for example my physics
professor in college discovered a new
phenomenon in nature it's that nuclei of
atoms resonate with electromagnetic
energy radiation
okay I've got a Nobel Prize for it that
phenomenon is called nuclear magnetic
resonance a clever engineer said but if
you can identify nuclei with this method
I can build a machine put you in that
machine and make a map of the different
nuclei that comprise your body some
nuclei is fat tissue some nuclei is
tumor tissue other nuclei is muscle
tissue thus was born the magnetic
resonance imager MRI correct
now they took it's really a nuclear
magnetic resonance imager because that's
what he discovered but that's one of the
forbidden n words you're not supposed to
take away the nuclear magnetic resonance
imager let me tell you some of this
engineers so smart why am I sitting in
that tube and I can't pump pump some
music in or something oh I'll take it up
with them yes we were you in the tube
that long couple of days my body is very
stubborn they were finding things in my
body
he's you're not supposed to eat peas
since I was a kid
okay my favorite MRI joke please okay it
was from oh you would have all right yo
who's that who's the comedian very
deadpan like it even right Stephen right
Stephen right right like if Salvador
Dali's art work comedy he would be it
okay so Stephen right he said I'm gonna
have an MRI to see if I'm claustrophobic
[Laughter]
right let's just check the brain to see
if the brain tells you if you're close
before you in African alright so we're
well so that's an example of the science
had to pre-exists
the engineering application of it the
original MRI without the science that
got the Nobel Prize hang on okay so the
best thing for an engineers have science
laying around with no one did anything
clever with it yet that's the best kind
of engineering solutions I've ever seen
but how about creativity that was the
question right where does creativity
come from that's what I was gonna say is
that invention of that your professor
discovery made the is that considered
created well there's a difference
creativity that is not science is
unbounded creativity that is science if
you don't come up with it somebody else
will bounded by the laws of nature and
yes science in science nature is the
ultimate judge jury and executioner of
your idea in art I guess public
sentiment is the judge jury and
executioner but that can shift and that
could be anymore not or not or whatever
one person creates it and feels it's
beautiful
and right right nothing's preventing you
from creating anything you want but
nature's are preventing me from
discovering anything I want so that's
why Beethoven's Ninth Symphony and Van
Gogh's Starry Nights are unique
creations in the human mind
whereas Einstein's relativity it's not
unique if he didn't do it somebody else
would have a few years later maybe
several people stapled together because
it to be equal as smart as he was so the
nature the creativity manifests
differently but hang on a second
regarding Einstein I I can't buy that
there's not some creativity some nuances
that you look at a problem differently
than another astrophysicist yes I'm at
it in a different way yes and isn't that
by definition creativity or a formula
I'm not saying it's not crazy well I'm
saying it is and you're gonna listen to
me you got a we gonna get bad I'm
serious so Paul I'm not saying it's not
creative I'm saying it's a different
kind of creativity I cannot pull
anything out of my ass and say this is
the this is how nature works
you can pull anything out of your ass
and say this is art you know and I had
principal you can do that right and of
course not all all art survives not all
artists get famous and their reasons
they're not somehow connecting to the
human condition in ways that other
artists do I get that I'm just saying if
van Gogh didn't paint sorry night no one
ever will paint it ever in the future
history of the human species but are you
saying a scientist can only apply laws a
certain way that and can't do it in a
creative way that's unique to that you
can whatever your creativity is it's
bounded by the laws of nature that
enable the world as it is you only do so
much with the way things are in terms of
the laws of nature correct there you go
so I so I like creativity it's just
manifest a little differently that's all
and you need definitely need and want
creative engineers you definitely want
creative scientists but the engineer can
invent stuff with pre-existing laws of
physics they can improve on things that
no one else saw we've made major
improvements on the internal combustion
engine from the earliest days these are
engineers over the decades now we have
electric cars that's a whole jump into
another place now they can benefit from
another century of creative engineers
perfecting the electric car and then
driverless cars and the driverless cars
and the like so those are engineers
perfecting on things that are not
invoking new laws of physics but I think
the most fertile engineering ideas have
a fresh law of physics ripe for the
picking theythey now let me create
something on earth that's never been
here before some machine that exploits a
law of physics that we just discovered
that's the coolest stuff out there and I
consider that creativity I didn't say it
wasn't creativity okay we are in violent
agreement really next question okay this
is an zaman Sam a Facebook is it
possible to travel back in time by going
to another universe that is exactly the
same as ours but different time zones
okay so in a multiverse our current
thinking is that if there's an infinite
number of multiverses there's another
universe where all these same molecular
configurations exist except you have
some evil goatee and mustache it's the
evil and everything else is the same
right okay is that still a thing yeah
yeah you need it yeah if you evil people
have to like stroke something you know
is it the cat but what is it they have
like nervous whatever the evil person
has so it can't be a toy cat no no it's
like just like a little furry yeah it's
got to be real yes so so with that you
can imagine a universe shifted in time I
don't have a problem imagining that
here's the difference even if your
entire molecular configuration is
reproduced in that other universe I'm
not convinced it to you I'm just not
convinced of that because of my DNA
makeup no it's identical to you it's
just not you because of that pert 'that
that entities life experiences are
different than mine no because it's a
it's a parallel universe where all of
that is the same same mother same up
well--don't sorry saying the molecules
configurations are all so what does that
does that entity if I'm at 512 off my
buddy can scrape my knee that that
experience happen to that entity
there'll be multiple universes where
that happened when you were three five
seven nine eleven didn't happen could
have happened happened bad happened good
you died in this other one because a
truck hits you all those combinations
would exist so you find the one that's
closest to ours but shifted by ten
minutes that's this question so the
money can you go back in time into that
life and all I'm saying is I'm not
convinced that your consciousness is
transportable in that way I can make an
exact replica of you over here
is your consciousness occupying this the
reason why I'm skeptical is we already
have examples of identical people they
call twins but they don't share each
other's conscious they are separate
people they might finish each other
sentences because they're raised
together and they do the same thing
differently they logic differently
they they they they they're not the same
people
even though they are genetically
identical that's my point and so if
you're not the same person this is my
fear of the transporter in Startalk in
Star Trek all right
beam me up Scotty your body and soul and
soul are down there and they beam me up
into the ship what they did was they
disassembled your atoms and reassemble
them over here are you the same person
or are you a photocopy of the same
person if you're just a photocopy then
do you share all of the consciousness I
think therefore I am I think therefore
am I you how do you define consciousness
in this consciousness is I think it's a
poorly defined thing where everybody's
trying to define a very amorphous word
in this context it's amorphous in many
contexts there are whole books on
consciousness you know why they're still
publishing books on consciousness
because we don't know anything about
consciousness that's not true we know
something but the fact that it is an
active field of research the evidence of
this is that people keep publishing
books on it hmm
consciousness explained consciousness
re-explained
my version of consciousness their
version of consciousness this will
continue until we understand
consciousness and then no more books
will be written about it why do you
think it's because you're trying to
understand the thing that is making you
try to understand it it goes back to
another episode when we were talking
about the brain the mind the mind brain
only 10% how can my consciousness
understand itself that is a challenge
that we've yet to rise - do you think
it's worth pursuing or do you think it's
futile oh no I think anything that we
don't know is worth knowing you're
asking a scientist is it worth knowing
you know definitely check it out and it
may be that consciousness is just
something else some illusion of
something else that act that's actually
going on in our brain but this is the
it's like on earth though it looks like
we're in the center of all motion and it
looks that way and it feels that way we
feel like we have a consciousness but go
to the heart of it no we're in orbit
around the Sun hmm we're not in the
center of anything there's some other
thing going on /
just fail you probably ran out of time I
know it take so much time to answer
question because is that okay if I do
that you yeah you know we know you like
to hear yourself talk you know I'll just
shut up from now on I don't have to say
anything no because this is why I keep
saying it you'd be you're great for
people because you take things to places
where you don't expect and you explains
in one question you get six answers
that's what rain is wired because the
whole world is connected and you can
just answer a question carbon
compartmentalize but that's not where
the fun thinking happens no and then so
you know literally in every question
that I've done with you over the last
couple of shows there have been six or
five revelations per question for me
really had nothing to do with the
question Oh completely use this
information that I'll never use that's
what useless means no you have to define
useless information that I will never
use this is the high you don't get if I
invited more parties right there you
just can't use information you can't let
it go you know what's true about this
useless relation I never use it
you got me Paul we gotta go yes yeah all
right so much fun you know and Paul
material that was and will continue to
be yes Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and in this episode of
star talk cosmic queries quirky queries
it was as always I bid you to keep
looking up I'll show you my math stash
like you're an evil
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]